八十八に行きます タッラービラティンニラティミッチェイエヒットワカーメアキンチェノ
パリオデペイアッターナンチッタクリーセーヒパンドイト
それでタットラ そこにアビラティンニッチェイア
そこに気持ち入れてくださいと
喜びなさいと そこにということは
このヴィヴェーカ 離れること
存在は依存である 依存から離れることに気持ちを入れてください
それはそこに達したいなと
そんなすごいことだったら
やっぱり達してみたいという風に気持ちを作ってほしいんですね
例えば自我が 本来の自分がもう全くもう黒いんだったら
悪だったらね これすぐ捨てた方がいいよって言ったら
あ できることならそこをやりたいと
いう気持ちを起こしてほしいと
ことなの ヒットワカーメ
あの 現に非切身に依存すること
それはやめてアキンチェノ
何にも何もないというものに
何にも依存しないという境地に喜びを感じなさいと
アキンチェナントというのは何もないということで
いわゆる大乗仏教の言葉でいえば空ですね
あの 何もないという そちらに喜びを感じなさいと
仏教では空という言葉は使わない
その代わりにこの無執着の境地
執着しないということ
何にも執着しないということが空なんですね
あの間違った単語を使うと
空という単語っていうのは
単語だけ独り歩きするんであって
意味は持ってないんです
具体性がないんです だからアキンチェナは具体性のある意味のある空なんです
何にも依存しないということ
で 龍樹さんが言った空論も因果法則だから
因縁論だからね 因縁により生まれるものには実体はないんだと
相対的であると そういうことだから
このもう何にも執着しないということが正しい言葉なんです
そちらに喜びを感じてくださいと
パリオデペイアッターナン
自分の心を清らかにしなさいと
自己を清らかにしてください
パリオデペイアっていうのは掃除しなさい
洗濯しなさいということなんです
ピュリファイ 清潔にしなさい
自我を 自我ではない 自己を清らかにしなさい
それからチッタクリーセーヒ
汚れを落としていったら
汚れもチッタクリーセー
心の汚れなんですね 煩悩のことなんです
だから心にある欲 怒り
憎しみ 嫉妬 落ち込み 高慢
自慢 自我などなどが汚れなんです
そこを洗って綺麗にしなさいと
だからお釈迦様すごい具体的なんです
心の掃除しなさい 心の洗濯しなさいと言った場合は
なんでとか これこれで汚れてますから
汚れもちゃんと説明してるんですね
だから我々は服を洗うとか洗濯機に放り込みますけど
心から 服につく汚れもいろんな種類があるんですよ
だから洗剤で何でも取れるわけじゃないんです
特に日本の洗剤では汚れは落ちません
そのまんまなんです だから必ず汚れる前に洗濯しなくちゃいけないんです
毎日 汚れたら服を捨てることになるんです
だからお醤油でもかけたら洗濯機にひいて出してみてください
お醤油のあの色がなくなるのかと
なくならんでしょうに
そのまんま ではスパゲティでも食べてなんか汚しちゃったら
もう大抵あれなんでしたっけ？トマトでなんて言いますか
ケチャップでもね 付いちゃうと
もう跡がなくならないんですね
素晴らしい専門家はね
見事に綺麗にして見せるでしょ
だから高価な着物とかなんとかとかね
汚れちゃうし それも で
お醤油もこぼれるわもう口紅もついたりするわ
いろいろ汚れますよ その場合は洗濯機に放り込みませんね
専門でやってる人に頼むんですよ
その人々 あの汚れはあっちこっち行かないように
見事にその場所だけで
その適した繊細だけ あの
あの あの綿あれ 何て言いますか
コットン 綿棒でね 綺麗に下に何か吸い込まれるために何か布を敷いて
上からどんどんと だけやりますよ
それから見事に全く見えないという
だから汚れによって洗い方があります
専門世界 そういう世界なんです
お釈迦様は心にはこういう
こういう こういう こういう汚れがあるとハッキリとリストアップしているんです
その汚れがこういう方法で
こういうことでなくなりますよと
大雑把でいい加減じゃないんです
ブッダの話はいつでも精密なんです
そういうことで 心の汚れはチッタクレーサ
煩悩であるんですね そこはパンリと理性のある人が
あの無執着の境地には欲しいなと思う
頭の悪い人々は幸福で生きていきたいなと思うんです
豊かで幸福で それもできないしね
残念ながらそれもブッダの道を歩む人々は豊かで幸福で生きているんです
他はみんな最悪状態で金があったってもひどく苦しんで生活するんです
仏教の人々は金がなくてもものすごい喜んで笑って生活しているんです
だから悔しいでしょうと思いますよ
みんな色んな高価なものに囲まれて
金がいっぱいあっても
人生は最悪 笑えない 神経質
夜眠れない そんなもの何もなく
その日で その日で何か手に入ったものを食べて生活する仏教の人はすごく喜んでいるんです
お釈迦様は本当にむちゃくちゃからかってますよ
だからもう悟りに頑張らなくたって
ブッダの道を歩む人はすごく幸せで
それは金があっても幸せ
金がなくても幸せ ざまみろということなのよ
他の人々には 結婚は神様が決めるとは全然ブッダが言ってないんですよ
お前らアホだからお互いに執着しているんだよと
そういう風に言うのに
仏教の人々は離婚しないんですよ
だからざまみろということでしょ
神が選んだ人とは人も回
回離婚するんです あれ
神が結構失敗してますね
神の前で約束して もうそれはもう神が選んだ人と
それでも年経つ前にもう離婚です
それでまた神がもう一人選んでくれて
それでも頑固と神は信じるという
一回神の判断を間違ったら
もう二度とその人に頼ってはいかないでしょうに
お釈迦様はそんなことなくね
こんな執着はね このまだ頭が悪いんだからと
だからお互いにすごく絶対執着して
という風に言うのに利口にならないんです
お釈迦様がだったらお互いに心配し合って
相手のことをとても尊く感じて
侮辱しないで 日々頑張りなさいよと
我儘を言い張るんじゃないよと
自分の家内やと旦那と夫やと思ったりしてとかね
そうなってくるとうまく幸せで生きていられます
だから そういうふうな世界です
仏教は そういうわけで
このパンリトという言葉がかなり厳しいんです
理性がないとやらないということなんです
はい 最後の偈に来ます
これが純粋に これこの三偈も出家に言ってるんです
だから私の解説もすごく難しくなるんです
イエーサンサンボーディアンゲスサンマーチッタンスバービタン
イエーサンサンボーディアンガっていうのは
悟りに達するために 昇格に達するために必要な部分パート
ボーディアンガ七つあります
我々は人格七つがありまして
全部精密に計算してやります
この七つの人格を育てるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で第一番目に挑戦するんですね
七 七覚支と言いますけど
サティという気づきに
そこを育てると二番目
三番目もどんどんどんどんついてきます
その七つを完成させなくちゃいけないんですね
サンマーチッタンスバービタン
それで心を育てるんですね
心を育てたということは
この七つの項目が心にあるんです
気づきがあって 分析能力があって
分別能力があって 精進というね
負けず嫌いの気持ちも入って
それから  喜覚支だと思いますけど
三番目 四番目 心に喜びがあって
平安覚支  ワンギーさんが言うんだから特に信頼なくなっちゃう
とにかくありますからという
で 私はもうすぐ思い出せませんだからね
サティダンモイチ  朝と参ってますから
で 平安と捨というね まあ一応心育てたということは
その七つがあるということになるんですね
アーダーナパティニッサゲアヌパーダーイラタ
アーダーナっていうのは執着のことで
執着何にも執着することパティニッサゲしてしまいますね
それからアヌパーダーエ
無執着のところに喜びを感じる
それでキーナーサワ 彼らが悟ったことになりますと
ジュティーマンタ輝いていますよと
悟った人は テーローケパリニブタ
彼らがこの世の中で涅槃に入られたと言えるんだよと
パリニブタっていうのは
このもうもう何か消えたという涅槃という意味なんですけど
それはこの生きることを山火事のように見るんですね
このオーストラリアなんかに時々山火事が来ちゃうと
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃったでしょ
最近 山火事が起きちゃって
人々もたくさん死にましたし
もうどうにもならん この山火事がサッと消えたらいかに安らぎかというと
その単語でパリニブタ
火が消えた状態という
そういう単語を使っているんですね
パリニブタっていうのはこの火が消える意味なんです
だから山火事で火がボーボーと燃え続けていると
もう極まりのない危険なんですね
落ち着かないんです 逃げても落ち着かないんです
いきなり雨が降って 山火事が雨でなくなりますからね
人間いくら頑張ってもどうにもならんでしょうに
雨が降ったらサッと消えちゃう
それで初めて安心ということになるんですね
そういうことで 輪廻転生することは山火事
生きるということは山火事のようなすごい危険なことで
そこをなくになると なくなるためには心を育てなくちゃいけない
心を育てるということは七つの項目がありまして
それを育てなくちゃいけないんです
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想でこの七つを実践させるんですね
はい ここでこの阿羅漢って何なのかっていう説明なんですよ
悟った人は何なのかという説明なんです
だから出家に語ったんです
出家がまだ悟ってない人々に阿羅漢に
だからその目的で出家したんだからね
だから俗世間の真似するんじゃないんです
俗世間の真似じゃなくて
全く反対の道を歩んで
こういう境地に達しますよと
これをブッダの言葉なんです
はい 話は終わりです  はい